George Bush and Dick Cheney
started new Wars in Iraq and Afghanistan.
Obama started new Wars in Libya and Yemen.
What new wars did Donald Trump start?
You go down the list,
and when you look at things
like the destruction of Iraq
or the implementation of a torture regime,
what has Donald Trump done
that even remotely compares
in terms of moral evil to any of that?
Nothing,
and yet, no, we're supposed to treat
George Bush and Barack Obama
like morally upstanding statesman
and Donald Trump like the
literal reincarnation of Hitler.
There's no journalist
who is more relentlessly iconoclastic
than Glenn Greenwald who
won the 2014 Pulitzer Prize
for his reporting on
the Snowden revelations.
Though unapologetically progressive,
the 53 year old former lawyer
never shrinks from fighting with the left.
A week before the 2020
election he quit the Intercept,
the online news site
he co-founded in 2014,
because by his account,
it refused to run a
story unless he removed
all sections critical of Joe Biden.
Denouncing what he
called "the pathologies,
illiberalism, and repressive mentality"
to led him being censored
by his own media outlet,
Greenwald railed that
"these are the viruses
that have contaminated virtually
every mainstream center-left
political organization,
academic institution, and news room."
Like a growing number
of refugees from more
traditional news organizations,
Greenwald took his talents to Substack,
a platform for independent
content creators
to earn revenue directly
from their audiences.
He wasted no time lobbing grenades,
posting stories and videos with titles,
like No Matter the Liberal Metric Chosen,
the Bush/Cheney Administration
was Far Worse than Trump.
And The Three Greatest
Dangers of Biden/Harris:
Militarism, Corporatism, and Censorship,
All Fueled by Indifference.
I spoke with Greenwald via
Zoom at his house in Brazil,
where he lives with his husband,
two children, and numerous dogs.
Among other topics,
we discussed what he sees
as a generational fight
playing at a newsrooms,
the challenge identity politics
poses to free expression,
and whether a coalition of
libertarians and progressives
can effectively push
non-interventionist foreign policy,
lifestyle liberation, and an
end to corporate subsidies
during the presidency of Joe Biden.
Glenn Greenwald, thanks
for talking to Reason.
Always happy to be with Reason.
Good to see you, Nick.
Yes, let's see.
Let's start with your
leaving the Intercept,
which you announced less than
a month ago as we're talking.
And in the piece that you wrote
explaining why you left this amazing
publication platform
that you helped start
only a few years ago,
you said that you were witnessing
or experiencing "The same
trends of repression,
censorship, and ideological homogeneity
plaguing the national press."
So what happened?
Well, some of you may recall
that when I created the Intercept
with Laura Poitras and Jeremy Scahill,
it was at the height of the
Snowden story back in 2013,
I was at the Guardian at the time,
and I had received a lot
of support institutionally
and editorially from the Guardian.
But I began noticing as I worked
with other media outlets
to report that story,
a lot of internal obstacles
that I thought were quite
difficult to overcome
in terms of doing the kind of reporting,
not just with that story, but in general,
I thought needed to be done.
And because Laura and I
had a lot of visibility
with that story, and Jeremy had done
a lot of high visibility
reporting of his own,
including having produced a film
about Obama's war on
terror called "Dirty Wars"
that had received an Oscar nomination,
We had a lot of leverage to
create a new media outlet.
And we obviously didn't do that
given that we all had very
good platforms at the time
to replicate what was already being done.
We only left the places we were at,
which were very secure,
because we thought we could do
something different in journalism.
And one of the principle visions
we had was that
we thought the model for how journalism
is often conducted inside
corporate media outlets,
which is this hierarchal
top-down structure
where editors impose, not
necessarily an ideology
as much as a kind of tone,
so they flatten out the vibrancy
and personality and voice in journalism,
make everything sound the same,
make everything adhere
to these very rigid rules
of how you can express yourself,
what kind of views can be heard,
with stifling journalism
it was making it not just an effective,
but actually quite boring.
And the idea was it's
gonna be a journalism
led media outlet where editors are there
to help you when you need
it to kind of kick the tires
on stories to make sure that
things are factually sound,
but they're not the bosses.
They're not the people
you have to overcome
who decide whether you
can be heard or not.
And I had written into my contract,
just like I did at the Guardian and Salon,
that except in very rare cases
where there was a very
complex original reporting,
like in the Snowden story,
of the Brazil reporting we did last year
that I would just publish
directly to the internet
with no editorial intervention.
And that was the model we
thought we were building
that I thought I was building.
I never thought it had anything
to do with ideological dogma,
and certainly never fealty
to any political party.